hello everybody and welcome to part 5 I
think I think part 5 of let's play
lacasa oh man ok you just got into a
room of delusions here that's good I
don't know if I should be glad or if I
should be terrified terrified discovery
like this would have my name in college
text no I won't I doubt I'll live long
enough to see your first edition yeah
you're dead this this is a sacred place
so gargantuan labs out against you in
journalistic sacrifices 2pc Aztec god of
discord the Jaguar Ted Scotland Cobra
Tezcatlipoca is described as a volatile
deity with the power to cure all
diseases oh that's nice of trespasses
and free men of the more blessed
uh-huh instead of choosing the blessing
entities with his divinity
the Jaguar God deprived us for the sake
of his amusement fantastic it is said
that Ted Scott lopaka is the beginner of
war his name means we who are his slaves
fantastic phenomenal
would each choose a limb to bind uh-huh
then a fifth would plunge a knife to the
sacrifice and carve open his or her body
lovely removing the heart while it still
beats a lowly sounds great they would
place the organ in a bowl and toss the
body down from the top of the temple
uh-huh
the head would be removed and displayed
this temple it belongs to him uh-huh I
have managed to ignorant Lee stumble my
way far into its heart and now that's
the last shred of my sweet and begins to
vanish and I finally turn to run
I find myself caged oh I would have been
as that face book executioner now if you
weren't laughs your teen of writing in a
journal soothes me
as I come to the end of this entry and I
raise my head to the dark I see
something stirring coming to take my
heart
maybe you're just so crazy that you're
laughing oh my hands are still tingling
oh man oh no music stopped music
stopping is not a good sign
oh boy ah aha
back where I was okay all right
drawers remain mysteriously Owen opened
is there something in here nope nope
nope nope okay that was fun huh uh huh
okay this is still kibou me what's going
on where do I go what do I do
my journal say no mementos phenomenal I
got a key no I picked up a key a rusty
key where to go oh no oh no oh no no no
no
why is it so quiet I don't like it I
like it I like it
I don't like it oh I don't like it hey
look a little sunlight yeah
oh I don't like it Oh what was the point
of going back there oh don't make me go
back the tomb oh maybe I miss something
I must have missed something cuz I don't
have a key anymore
oh is messing with me this is definitely
messing with me okay carpets get out of
here with that key go I had the key oh
we're dead wait a minute that was not
there that was that was not there dad
I would have seen it okay whatever
whatever those spores have affected my
nervous system was I going mad yeah you
were and are oh man oh boy oh boy
okay locked Oh what's this alright
that's good
maybe there's a mechanism oh I'm so
strong I could have lifted him Yeah
right what's going on hello well
somebody there yeah hello the door's
locked on the other side take this key
okay you're a monster
back off please open it for me back off
man oh there please answer
huh what's going on what's going on whoa
no no no no what's going on
I don't like this I don't like this I
ran a boy who was that ha ha no not a
repeat of the mannequins no no no no no
no no no Shep off F up ah no no no no no
no no no no no I've reached a review a
reviews get out of here
okay okay no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no oh God okay okay
okay oh no no no no oh oh no oh [ __ ] me
I missed how stupid am I oh oh yeah oh
oh dad oh my god I do not like that that
was bad that's bad okay okay all right
okay
haha no no good Oh open you bastard why
are you why is this one fighting me Oh
open no open you EFT ah open up open the
[ __ ] up
Oh what the [ __ ] oh oh the return of the
penumbra wheel Oh get out of here get
out of here get out here get out here
good Joey get over there
oh you don't want to eat oh man
I need these boxes oh boy oh no too hard
to throw gosh guys ah ah
where did that one go ah come on damn
boxes Oh give me oh damn it aw damn it
oh damn it whatever ah oh yeah you're
gonna you get out of here okay all right
please tell me one is enough nope nope
get right there I do not like box
stacking get me okay
oh my goodness oh I want to get out here
I want to get out of here only gonna
have my boy let me Oh girls good oh man
oh man oh boy oh boy huh f off fo f off
f off huh no no no no no no no aah gimme
a box ha ha no no no no no no no no no
no no no Oh Oh baloney baloney sandwich
avila what the what Andy hell was that
sounded like a goat Oh get out of here
Oh get out of here
I'll get gifts Oh get in here oh boy oh
I do not like this is the X this this is
the opposite of good he's so very bad oh
I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna die I
die here
okay all right I'm keeping it together
oh wow
don't flip out on me carpet oh boy oh my
hands are shaking
Oh what was that was that what was that
oh no no no no no get good get out of
here get gonna get out of here get out
here no no Oh f off so hard
oh [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you moves man
oh oh oh what's you losing so dog ten I
don't need a doctor
was it was it a bones huh what do I have
a boat huh what why why why Oh get out
of here Wow no no no no no no no no no
Oh
huh I feel it's there's something
calling to me calling to me help me
we're luring me to my death Oh Oh big Oh
big empty room Oh God oh I have to cut
it here ah thank you so much for
watching I can't stop cuz I don't know
if it's gonna save so I'm gonna keep
going I'm gonna just take a little
breather let my hands stop shaking okay
thanks so much for watching see you in
the next part I don't remember which one
it is
bye bye bye bye bye bye